quiero que veamos otro ejemplo de un
inductor pero ahora con un interruptor
con un switch lo que tenemos aquí un
circuito con un inductor y con este
interruptor de botón que podemos apretar
y soltar pero cuando este interruptor se
acerca la placa metálica conecta estos
dos puntos cerrando el circuito este es
un circuito muy parecido al que vimos
anteriormente donde teníamos aquí un
circuito con un inductor sin el
interruptor y el voltaje tenía un pulso
subía y bajaba y volvía a subir y volvió
a bajar ahora si le agregamos un
interruptor tenemos unos efectos
secundarios bastante interesantes cuando
abrimos el interruptor pero antes de ver
esos efectos secundarios vamos a ver
algunos ejemplos de donde podemos
encontrar un inductor controlado por un
interruptor en la vida real tenemos
varios ejemplos pero vamos a empezar con
un solenoide un solenoide es una espiral
de cable que se ve más o menos así una
bobina
pero que además tiene una barra metálica
aquí en medio y luego cuando ponemos a
fluir corriente a través de este cable
la barra se mueve no crea esta barra
metálica gracias a la corriente se está
moviendo un ejemplo donde se usan los
solenoides es en los timbres ahora otro
ejemplo donde tenemos un inductor o una
bobina es un relevador los relevadores
tienen una bobina un cable enrollado así
y aquí esto es una especie de
electroimán pero por acá tenemos una
cosa metálica que se va a estar moviendo
acercándose y alejándose cuando la
corriente esté fluyendo a través de esta
bobina este se va a acercar por acá y
cuando deje de fluir la corriente va a
regresar a esta posición así es que si
por ejemplo aquí tenemos una conexión y
por acá tenemos otra conexión esta barra
metálica va a pasar de conectar este
circuito a desconectarlo cuando se
acerca
así es que los relevadores son una
especie de interruptores te los puedes
encontrar por ejemplo en los coches
controlando los limpiaparabrisas la
corriente pasa a través del interruptor
de los limpiaparabrisas en tu tablero
pero es una corriente mucho más pequeña
que la que se necesita para activar al
motor de limpiaparabrisas entonces
cuando activamos el interruptor de los
limpiaparabrisas se activa el relevador
que activa al interruptor de los motores
de los limpiaparabrisas y así ya no
necesita pasar tanta corriente por el
interruptor del limpiaparabrisas en tu
tablero pero bueno estos son sólo dos
ejemplos de dónde se utiliza cable
enrollado de esta forma y son ejemplos
que se aplican en la vida real ahora en
muchos casos la cantidad de corriente
que está fluyendo a través de estos
cables enrollados es grandísima y ahora
quiero que veamos qué pasa cuando
aprendemos y apagamos este switch en
este circuito así es que vamos a suponer
que tenemos un inductor de 10
y henry si vamos a tomar el interruptor
lo apretamos cerrando el circuito y
luego lo vamos a soltar ahora aquí
también nos tenemos que fijar en los
voltajes así es que por aquí tenemos un
voltaje este es el lado positivo
negativo y le vamos a llamar a este
voltaje b lo vamos a estar midiendo con
respecto a la tierra y también nos
interesa el voltaje a través de este
inductor ya este voltaje le vamos a
llamar b l ahora la suma de estos dos
voltajes siempre tiene que ser igual a 3
volts así es que vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando apretamos el botón conectando el
circuito y también vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando soltamos el botón y se desconecta
el circuito la verdad es que lo
interesante va a pasar como soltemos el
botón pero bueno empezamos así con el
botón abierto este circuito está abierto
así es que la corriente no está fluyendo
por lo que la corriente tiene que ser
igual a cero
y aquí le vamos a llamar y 0 porque es
la corriente inicial al tiempo cero la
corriente es igual a cero pero ahora al
tiempo cero vamos a cerrar el circuito
vamos a poner el interruptor por acá
este es nuestro interruptor cerramos el
interruptor al tiempo de igual a cero y
entonces de repente este inductor tiene
un voltaje y además es un voltaje de 3
volts y ahora vamos a utilizar la forma
integral de la ecuación de los
inductores para encontrar la corriente
que fluye a través del inductor así es
que tenemos que la corriente en un
tiempo t que no vamos a poner es igual a
la integral desde el tiempo cero hasta
ese tiempo te dé el voltaje a través del
inductor o sea b l en el tiempo tau con
respecto al tiempo tal y aquí me faltó
poner uno entre l
la corriente al tiempo cero bueno y
ahora vamos a resolver esto colocando
todo lo que sí conocemos así es que la
corriente es igual a 1 entre 10.000 y
henri por esta integral pero el voltaje
a través del inductor es constante de
hecho son 3 volts y como es constante
puede salir de la integral y nos queda
así 3 volts por la integral de cero
hasta t con respecto a tau + y 0 pero y
0 es igual a 0 y bueno ya terminamos de
resolver esto es igual la corriente es
igual a 3 volts entre 10.000 y henri por
la integral de 0 a t de tau es
simplemente una t y lo que esto nos dice
es que la corriente si la gráfica moss
con respecto al tiempo es una línea
recta con está pendiente igual que en el
vídeo pasado y aquí está pendiente o sea
que tanto aumenta la corriente con
respecto al tiempo son 3 volts entre
10.000 y henri pero eso es igual a 300
amperes por segundo así es que hay esta
corriente está aumentando rapidísimo ok
está pendiente es demasiado grande y si
la corriente va a aumentar así de rápido
pero en un circuito real aquí también
tendríamos algunas resistencias y
entonces esas resistencias determinarían
que tanto puede llegar a aumentar la
corriente pero con el propósito de
enseñarte cómo funciona esta ecuación
estamos viendo este caso hipotético sin
resistencias y así podemos calcular
fácilmente cómo cambia la corriente
cuando abrimos y cerramos el interruptor
pero bueno para poder seguir utilizando
este circuito y seguir avanzando en este
tema tengo que borrar todo esto y ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando abrimos este
switch acabamos de abrir este
y lo movimos hacia acá y entonces
tenemos una corriente inicial que va a
ser igual a una y que tanta corriente
inicial tenemos depende de cuánto tiempo
dejamos conectado este circuito entonces
tenemos esta corriente fluyendo en este
inductor y lo que queremos ver es qué
pasa cuando abrimos el interruptor y
entonces la corriente se va directamente
a cero porque eso es lo que hace el
interruptor si lo abrimos la corriente
ya no puede seguir fluyendo cuando
abrimos el interruptor en un momento
estaban tocándose estos dos componentes
y entonces fluye a la corriente y el
siguiente momento ya no se están tocando
y la corriente ya no fluye entonces si
nos fijamos en delta y el cambio
instantáneo en la corriente pues el
cambio es cero
la corriente final menos
la corriente inicial y si nos fijamos en
el cambio en el tiempo cuánto tiempo nos
tardamos en abrir el switch pues es algo
muy parecido a cero primero el switch
estaba cerrado y de repente el switch
ahora está abierto y bueno digamos que
el tiempo que nos toma abrir el switch
es de 0 segundos ahora aquí viene lo
interesante hay una cosa extraña que
pasa con los interruptores calculemos el
voltaje en el inductor justo en este
segundo cuando abrimos el interruptor
porque nosotros sabemos que el voltaje
es igual a l por la velocidad de cambio
de la corriente con respecto al tiempo y
ahora coloquemos los valores que
conocemos tenemos el y el cambio en mí
es de menos
con respecto al tiempo cero y de t es
cero y esto es igual a que pues es igual
a menos infinito pero ay qué rayos está
pasando aquí es posible que suceda esto
no claro que no
así es que hay detengámonos un momento
digamos que en lugar de decir que el
interruptor se abre en 0 segundos que se
abre en un nano segundo y tal vez esto
logre salvarnos pero bueno aquí tenemos
que el voltaje es igual a él por el
cambio en la corriente que es menos y
entre el tiempo que nos tardamos en
hacer el cambio que en este caso estamos
diciendo que es un nanosegundo ahora un
nanosegundo es 1 por 10 a la menos 9
esto a que es igual bueno pues es igual
a menos
por y por 10 a la 9 aunque con este 9
positivo y este es un número enorme no
les parece pero bueno ahora veamos un
ejemplo un poquito más concreto vamos a
suponer que empezamos con un voltaje de
10.000 amperes y entonces aquí tenemos
que el voltaje es igual a él que son
10.000 y henri estamos suponiendo que
empezamos con una corriente de 10.000
amperes y seguimos suponiendo que abrir
el interruptor es una cuestión que toma
un nanosegundo así es que dividimos
entre 1 por 10 a la menos 9 y ahora sí
vamos a calcular el voltaje tenemos 10
por 10
tenemos 1000 x 1000 y eso es como
multiplicar 10 a la menos tres por 10 a
lo menos 3 o sea que tenemos 10 a la
menos 6 entre 10 a la menos 9 nos queda
que es igual a multiplicar por 10 a la 3
o sea que aquí tenemos otros 3 ceros nos
faltaba por aquí poner este signo menos
y estos son volts y listo ya calculamos
el voltaje a través de este inductor en
el momento en el que abrimos el
interruptor y es de menos 100 mil volts
ahora esto lo que significa es que la
terminal negativa en este inductor tiene
un voltaje de 100 mil volts arriba que
el voltaje positivo y entonces en este
punto tenemos un voltaje de 100 mil 3
volts y no nos queda de otra que
preguntarnos cómo puede estar sucediendo
eso porque es un voltaje altísimo pero
bueno todo esto que vimos aquí es como
una especie de acertijo que tenemos
acerca de los interruptores
y para resolverlo tenemos que ver muy de
cerca al interruptor nos vamos a fijar
super cerca en el mundo real que es lo
que está pasando con estos interruptores
porque aquí es donde llega el mundo real
y nos salva de esta situación extraña de
estas cosas que nos están diciendo
nuestras ecuaciones que no tienen mucho
sentido así es que vamos a ver super
cerca esta área del interruptor tenemos
aquí la terminal del interruptor y aquí
tenemos la placa metálica del
interruptor en cuanto el interruptor se
aleja de la terminal aquí se genera un
espacio lleno de aire en un mundo ideal
este espacio de aire sería un aislante
perfecto pero lo que sucede como tenemos
estos voltajes tan extremos lo que
sucede es que este espacio de aire deja
de ser el aislante perfecto y se vuelve
un conductor y entonces por aquí vamos a
tener una chispa por la que está pasando
la corriente
y aquí se genera una chispa y esto es lo
que sucede en la vida real todo el
tiempo en muchos interruptores cuando
los abrimos se da esta chispa que es lo
que nos da suficiente tiempo como para
que no se acumulen cantidades
astronómicas de voltaje esta chispa
permite que la corriente siga fluyendo y
entonces el cambio en la corriente no
sea tan abrupto pero bueno supongamos
que este espacio de aire es de un
nanómetro la cantidad de voltaje que se
necesita para que la corriente fluya a
través de una nome tro de aire aislante
es de 3 mil volts ok si tienes 3 mil
volts o más la corriente si puede fluir
a través de un nanómetro de aire así es
que esto es lo que sucede en realidad en
muchísimos interruptores sí es cierto
que puedes hacer interruptores que
soporten estas chispas pero no es lo más
conveniente